♪♪
Babe, can we watch
something else?
I hate these movies.
Why?
'Cause I--
I fart when
I get scared.
( gasping )
( farting )
See?
Oh, come on,
it's cute.
No... it's gross.
( phone ringing on TV )
( sighing )
Oh, my God, this
really annoys me.
These dumb girls
always bring
their cell phones
with them to hide.
The killer
hears it.
That's how
they get caught.
( gasping )
( farting )
God...
I'm sorry.
It's all right.
Do you want
another beer?
Yeah, I'll take one.
You want me
to pause it?
No.
( gasping )
( farting )
Oh, my God, baby,
you scared me.
♪♪
( screaming )
( farting )
Jake... Jake!
No, no, no...
( farting )
( farting continues )
Come on, come on,
come on, come on, come on.
( phone ringing )
( farting )
Shut up, shut up,
shut up, shut up, shut up.
( door creaking )
( phone ringing )
( farting )
( floor creaking )
( phone ringing )
( screaming )
( farting )
( screaming continues )
( farting continues )
9-1-1 emergency,
this is Karen.
( Amy screaming )
( Amy farting )
( screaming )
( farting )
You see these
damn kids?
I'm sick of
these prank calls.
( screaming )
( farting )
( groaning )
Oh...
♪♪
( farting )